Hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Slayaway Camp!
Now we're on our second movie of what could
Possibly be literally dozens of movies
Here, but I have to play this game
Again just because it's -- it's so fun. Not for
Like the game itself; everything
Aurrounding the game, like the gameplay
is simplistic and it's just about
Blowing up
Oh, oh no --  it's just about everything else in it
Oh jeez... oh!
Flinged? That's the sound effect for a
Chainsaw death? Flinged? Not even
flung? Not even shook? Oh jeez.. Sorry. Sorry.
Alright, Danger Lakes. Like everything
else about this game combining into an
experience. God, what the fuck is wrong
with me, talking about experiences like
Ah-as if I know anything about it. You
gonna go into the lake? Did he drown? Was that drowning?
Oh. Oh. Oh, God. Why can't they swim? They have bathing suits!
Why can't they swim?!
Oh jeez. I'm sorry, apparently that was amazing.
I don't know. Right to remain deadly. Oh. Oh. How the-? How do I-?
Ohh, I can't attack him from the front.
That girl is high as shit.
HABEWSKI! Sorry, had to do it. Had to do it.
Alright now, how do I get out of here, because
Ahh! I- I done bad. Okay let me back off so,
what I gotta do here is come at her from the
other side - HABEWSKI! Sorry about that - ugh. (Noises)
Sorry.
'Scuse me. (Noises) That guy just died!
Okay apparently that doesn't cut
someone's head off but me punching
someone in the back of the head is enough.
Triple truncheon. Alrighty then. Kid
you are still not safe.
How do I-? Oh. Oh, now the puzzles are starting
to get a bit more complicated. So how... OH
I can slide past him, that's right! Haha
You should have been paying attention
there Bubbo.  Boop-a-doop, boop-a-doop, boop-a-doop.
Oh no! Oh, not the bees! Oh, no! Oh, God!
Oh, it's so horrible. Oh jeez...
I gotta unlock all of them and they're dead for some reason.
I guess entering the - ohh.. I guess entering the
demon portal just causes everyone to
explode from the residual energy.
No, not tryptophobia, trypaphobia, not
trippaphobia.. Oh good fear of holes. God I
actually legitimately have trypophobia.
Oh, sorry about that! ... I'm boned though.
I can't do that.
Okay so, yeah you can't go anywhere but
you're scared.
Oh, okay, I got it. Ha-boop-boop-boop, ha-boop-boop.
You look so happy over there, and yet you're
going to be so Dead.
If only I could figure out where to go from here... Well, I'm lost.
Hang on, hang on, I got this. I'm smart enough for this.
Hip, hip, hip, hip, hip, hip, hip - AH!
There we go now I got it.
We're all in the right order now, and
you're dead, and I'm sorry, I-I apologize
for nothing
Do I have a back story on this guy too?
Oh, God. Oh, God. Oh no, it's just - look, look!
Oh no, it's all-Jeez. Oh, God..
I mean it's lightened a little bit because they're just box figures.
It's like less than Minecraft graphics here.
Alright so there's gotta be a special
way to go about this because apparently...
Can't be just as easy as me going up
there because that would end in death
Wouldn'it? But if I were to go some other way
I might be able to can to wumpus the wumpeople
Yep. Haha! Got ya.
So then I-I-I wumpify you..
That means that I could wumpify... eugh, you with a headbutt from hell
Habewski. Haaabewski. Got it, nailed it!
And you're dead, for some reason. you're not
even emotional about it.... Okay I must be
growing less and less heartless because
I don't feel any remorse for any of
these deaths.. Kabin Krush! Alright.
That's (giggles) that's not nice! That's not nice at all..
Oh jeez!  Was that their eyes??
Did their eyes just roll out on the floor??
I mean it was only a 2D representation of eyes but even so.
Okay... Splatterlicious...
Forest Frenzy, finish in 7 turns... I don't know if I can!
I don't know if I wanna....
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, bam!
Oh jeez.. OHHHH! EUUUGGHH! It's so horrible!
I did it! I just don't feel- aw jeez.
Alright I need to stop freaking out about
these deaths, because the whole game's just
gonna be non stop this if I keep
freaking out - not gonna be able to get
anywhere in my-my life here.
Alright, bookcase bullies, you got it.
Knocked that one over.
Oh, thquith. Ha-boop -boop, ha-boop.
Oh, sorry sir!
Habewski! Okay so I gotta get back over
yonder is I'm just taking a while but
there we go got it! Okay. Hablewth.
Okay everyone's dead now! Can I go home?
Can I have a good time and go home?
Oh but what happens if I miss? - Yay!
They live and everyone's happy!
Except for me, the murderer who wanted to kill everybody.
Hotsprings Havoc!
Oh no.. Is this gonna
be another case where these kids somehow
mysteriously don't know how to swim?
I'm just operating under the base
assumption that that's the case.
Hah! Oh God, they're so dumb!
Why- Why does that kill them? I don't ge-
They came here to swim,  that was like their main purpose!
How are they dying from falling in water?
Swimming Hole Horrors...
Okay... Oh no I'm gonna, I'm gonna kill
somebody with a porta-potty.
Oh I'm about to kill someone with a porta-potty!
Ehhh! K-niffed!
Ohh.. But I can't get to the exit if I do that
Ohhh..
So, I have to - I have to
Cease the, uh, murderlicious urge
to kill someone with a porta-potty.
I have to try to not... do that.
Ohh, what have you done?! You killed your friend!
Okay so that's not the correct move.
But I bet
this is. Habewski!
Alright, so, now, I'm gonna get back for ya
Habewski!
Sorry, had to do it.
Oh I can't do that. No but they're gonna run
Oh, so I need to, uh I need to stop the
porta-potty from being pushed over... gross.
Then I need to come up here.. (screams) you're dead.
Yeah, sorry about that, had to happen.
Then I can go! I got it with my brain.
And you got it in your brain.
Slash the teens before the SWAT team arrives, finish in 6 turns.
Oh man that's a lot to kill. Alright then
I'm up to a challenge.
So if I... run away! Oh. Run away!
That wasn't the right way to run.
I did not do this correctly. Nope, didn't do that!
Is it gonna be like - oh, it's gonna be like a chain reaction
You run, you got- murder scares you!
You're all so stupid, and now you're dead.
Now how do I get back there in two turns? Hang on.
So, that's the question. Why-
why is this guy not scared by me getting near him there
and this won't do it, 'cause he'll run the wrong way.
Aww... Wait you meean the correct way to
solve it isn't to do the chain reaction
of spooks into the fire?? But that's such
a cool way to do it
Aw,  man I thought that was gonna be it.
Ehh! Sorry! Uwwww..
Alright, I guess, I guess I'm gr- oh.
Final scene! Please, make it stop.
Ohh... (giggles) Oh, jeez...
Oh no. Oh no. Ohhh (giggles).
Oh but the cute little bunny!
The cute little bunny is so happy about the music.
It's good!
Probably not that good but it's- it's alright.
Oh boy, dude! Oh boy!
Hup, hup, hup, HABEWSKI!
Well, I guess I'm not a fan of- OOOH
Silenced...
Wow. That just goes to show you don't-
don't go into the middle of the woods
singing about friendship because
obviously I do not want anything to do
with our friendship.
Another return to slayaway camp
Slayaway camp 2.5
Oh my God, I love this.
And there's so much to do in it, it's awesome!
C-Flat Face, Origami 'd, Pruned,
Party's Over, Pincushioned, Cinco de Slayo
Puffed Up. Oh God! A leaf blower's a creative
killing cont- Oh, God! I kinda want it
but I'm not ready for that, emotionally.
Or any way.
Urban skull-face? Poorly received urban
skull-face revamp from the shelved
Slayaway camp 12, Skullz in da Hood.
Oh jeez (giggles).
Okay, so, either way, that is all
I'm gonna play about this game, I don't
think I'm gonna do a full playthrough of it
just because I'd eventually get
tired of the puzzles, and then you guys
would, you know,
watch me be slowly be more and more
terrible throughout the game. But this
game is fun like legitimately. It has
charm, it has, like, gameplay to it,
it's got puzzles and it's got other elements on
top of it and i really like that so!
Thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what're your thoughts down in the
comments below, and as always i'll see you
in the next video! Buh-bye!